(man) the sharks are back,
looking for the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
If they hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
why would I ever give you money
at a value that guarantees
I'll never get a return?
Here's the thing.
It's a $54 billion industry.
The biggest players--
Every guy comes in here
and says that.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
What's it gonna take?
Twice the money you came
here looking for.
Before you make a decision, I'm
gonna try to change his mind.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
The waste products can be
$96 billion in gold.
Gold?
Gold.
It's very interesting,
but most of it's
nutbar factor six.
I'm obsessed
with them already.
The feeding frenzy is about
to begin. (chuckles)
who are the sharks?
They're five self-Made,
filthy rich investors.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-Filled city
of manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-Shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-Made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
My name is Brenda Coffman,
and I'm from kokomo, indiana.
(whirs)
I own and operate
retail cookie stores
throughout the state of indiana
and Florida.
I am a hometown girl,
and I married
my high school sweetheart,
and we have
two wonderful children
who are the pride and joy
of our life.
During college,
to make ends meet,
I started baking
and selling cookies
on Friday and saturday nights.
(chuckles)
How many minutes are
on that timer?
Everyone loved the cookies,
and so I thought,
what a great time to start
a cookie business.
(Brenda) Hi.
Welcome to blondie's cookies.
How are you folks today?
(Brenda) I want to come
to the shark tank
because I want their help
to grow this company
into a household name.
I want everyone to know
blondie's cookies.
♪♪♪
Hi, everyone.
My name is Brenda Coffman,
but please call me blondie.
I'm the proud founder
and operator
of blondie's cookies inc.,
where we handcraft
over 25 varieties
of the best cookies and brownies
you'll ever taste.
I'm here seeking $200,000
for a 3% equity
in blondie's cookies inc.
3%?
3%.
(daymond and Barbara laugh)
I began baking--
I began baking when I was
just 15 years old.
My family Encouraged my baking,
and I quickly figured out
I was pretty good at it.
With a lot of support
from my husband mark
and my wonderful mom Betty,
my passion grew,
and so did our new
small little cookie business.
I wanted to be
the next mrs. Fields.
Today blondie's cookies
owns and operates
12 retail locations
in indiana and Florida.
Oh, but wait, sharks.
Be patient.
The feeding frenzy is about
to begin. (chuckles)
(chuckles)
Thank you, blondie.
You're welcome. Enjoy.
You're like a--You're like
a cartoon figure.
Enjoy.
Oh. (chuckles)
Really.
Enjoy.
Thank you.
(daymond) Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Blondie.
(Brenda) You'll be sampling
our top five Sellers tonight,
starting with
our famous Sprinkle cookie.
It's a vanilla shortbread with
our signature buttercream icing.
Then we have
our cocoa swirl cookie,
which is
a dark chocolate shortbread
and a ganache frosting.
Chocolate Chip is next,
white chocolate macadamia...
ohh.
And last But not least,
our macadamia chewy bar. Wow.
Very sweet.
Wow.
That is fantastic.
When was the last time
you had something
that tasted that good
for under $2?
Blondie?
Yes.
Uh, I can't help
but ask...
(laughs)
$200,000...
yes.
For 3%.
Yes.
That means you're valuing
these cookies
for over $5 million.
Our sales--
Over $6 million.
Our sales last year alone,
guys, were $2.3 million.
Our sales are scheduled
at $2.5 million for 2011.
How much money did you make?
Uh, last year was
a flat year.
We opened four stores in Florida
all in the same time period,
and, um,
with that investment,
we--we didn't have
a profitable year yet.
Why so many at once?
It seems very, very aggressive.
Yes,
in different territories.
Well, that's a very--
That's a very good question,
but when we knew
we were expanding that far,
for logistics purposes alone
and for branding purposes,
we knew we had to have
more than one location.
Help me understand.
You have the eight in indiana,
and then you move
to Florida.
Florida--a positive now,
or is it still a drag?
And what your plans are
for those units.
Well, two of the stores
in Florida
are still not a year old,
and I think
what we underestimated
as a business was that
we didn't realize how popular
we were in indiana.
We didn't realize how good
we were.
That's a nice spin there,
blondie.
Thank you.
(laughs)
Blondie, do you have
any other investors?
All right, so you're saying
the Florida stores are
losing a lot of money?
They are losing a lot of money
their first year, yes.
(mark and Kevin) How much?
Um, hmm. Uh, let's see.
Probably about $175,000.
So that was a mistake,
wasn't it, going to Florida?
I don't think it's a mistake.
I'm not a quitter. I'm not.
That's not the point.
Sometimes--
Right.
Well...
you don't want to put
good money after bad.
I still think the markets are
wide open there, though.
We just haven't--
What makes you say that?
I mean, you know--
Well, because we haven't--
in--we haven't captured
the corporate clients
in Florida like we have
in indiana.
And do you have any--
Do you have any bank loans?
Sure we do.
How much debt do you have?
Um, about $800,000.
(men) Ohh.
Blondie.
♪♪♪
All the sharks are still in,
but they've uncovered
information
that may have tanked
Brenda's prospects.
Do you have any bank loans?
Sure we do.
How much debt do you have?
Um, about $800,000.
(men) Ohh.
Yeah,
for the four new stores.
Blondie.
Right.
Blondie, you have to add...
wow.
Your debt to the value,
so you've just raised
your multiple
into the stratosphere.
Never in the history
of the planet earth
or the PLANET zutron has
a bakery traded...
(chuckles)
for over a 20 multiple ever,
so you'd have to go
to the planet negatar.
Well, never in the history
of planet neutron has
a bakery done $2.5 million.
Look, I love your shtick
and your smiling
and all that stuff, but you're
making me a little crazy
with this valuation,
'cause there's nothing
proprietary about your cookies.
I can hire a granny,
put on a yellow outfit,
smile like you do, and have her
bake these in an oven.
You can't.
You cannot hire a granny--
Yes, I can.
Yes, I can, blondie...
No, you can't.
All day long.
What you are investing in
is four things.
We have
a wonderful brand name that,
once people have
the product,
they immediately
become brand loyal.
Number two, there is nothing
on the market that tastes
like blondie's cookies,
absolutely nothing.
Number 3,
we have systems of 26 years.
I didn't start doing this
yesterday.
I have been doing it for
26 years in the mid--Midwest,
which is
an extremely tough market.
And fourth, you have me,
one of the hardest-Working
c.E.O.S I know.
I'm out.
Okay. I understand.
Blondie, I think you've done
a phenomenal job
of creating a brand.
I think you gotta--
You gotta pull in the horses
and focus on the core,
uh, not the remote locations.
I'm out.
Mrs. Fields grow--Grew
to millions and millions
of dollars
before they were purchased
by a larger company.
We have the best product
on the market,
and we know
what we're doing.
We're
a proven turnkey operation.
I'm not asking you to come in
and run my business.
I know how to do cookies,
but you know business,
and you know how
to go to those next levels,
and you know how to
get past those plateaus.
You know, blondie...
(sighs) I don't like you.
(laughs)
Because of you,
I'm gonna be in the gym
for about three hours
tonight.
(Brenda and Barbara laugh)
These cookies are good.
Thank you.
Where your business is
right now, you went for it,
and it hasn't quite turned out
the way you planned,
but that's created
a significant problem
for an investor,
because my only hope
of getting my money back is
completely dependent
on what happens in Florida.
Right.
You are all-in, right?
Well, how many businesses
expand 45% in one year?
Well, look, what happened is
what happened, right,
but you're asking me
to put good money
to help support
what you already are--
Is telling us
is bad money...
right.
And that's the problem.
Well, the numbers
we talked about--
blondie, I'm out.
Barbara? Daymond?
I tasted the cookies.
Blown away.
Thank you.
I'm--I'm obsessed
with them already.
Thank you.
Then I started becoming
mesmerized by you.
I believe you're the brand.
But 3% for $200,000,
and you're valuing
the business at $7 million--
No, not--More than that
with debt.
$9 million, I think,
she's--
More than that with debt,
So, okay, $9 million.
I'm out.
Okay. I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm just gonna tell you
what I really think,
which is a hard thing
to do...
Sure.
Because you're like
a little bubbly Angel here.
That's okay.
I feel like, uh,
you've made a big mistake
in opening the Florida stores,
and I think on some level,
you know it,
but what's gonna work
against you,
'cause I know--I have
a good share of that in myself--
Is your refusal to quit.
That, plus your honor.
I could tell right away,
you're the type of person,
you commit to something,
you--You mean it.
Sure. Our balance sheet's
not looking good
because we pay our bills.
No.
We don't bow out.
And you'll pay your bills
until you die
on your own sword.
That's right.
I'm out.
Okay. Appreciate that.
By the way, I'm gonna eat
All those cookies, so... sorry.
(chuckles)
They're all for you guys.
I'm a customer.
Thank you.
Thanks, blondie. Good luck.
I'm a little disappointed,
but I've never given up
in 26 years,
and I'm not giving up now.
We have the best product.
It's all about the cookie
at blondie's.
♪♪♪
Next up is Ben wood,
who believes his technology
can be a game changer
in the clothing business.
♪♪♪
My name is Ben wood.
My company is viewsport.
I'm seeking $500,000 in exchange
for 20% equity in my company.
Anyone working out,
be it at home, in the gym,
or in a training camp,
wants to see results.
That's why they do it.
But to get results,
you need to push yourself,
and more often than not,
we're willing to buy
whatever gear necessary
to help us achieve
these results.
That's why I created
viewsport.
Viewsport
sweat activated technology
is built into the fabric
of t-Shirts, so when you sweat,
a secret logo appears
in the shirt.
It's motivation...
(chuckles)
Through perspiration.
Mm.
Here's how it works.
Cody begins his workout.
He starts to perspire.
Fast-Forward 20 minutes
into Cody's workout.
(spritzing)
(chuckles)
His shirt just became
personal motivation,
and you can customize
any of these shirts
to have whatever logo
you like appear.
When you need
that extra boost,
that extra push
in your workout,
viewsport's gonna do it
for you.
The market is crying out for
something new, and we have it.
We just need your relationships
and capital to help drive sales.
What are the sales?
This year we've done
$140,000,
80% of which has been done
in the last 3 months.
Can I see one?
Sure. How about this one?
So you can see it
and appreciate it.
And is this your technology
you invented,
or did you license it?
No. This is my technology.
I invented it,
and it's patent pending
right now.
How did you invent it?
My background's
in chemistry.
I was in medical school,
and I was working out...
(Robert chuckles)
And I saw sweat patterns
on my shirt.
(chuckles) I thought it would
be kind of a novel idea
to create messaging
out of it,
so I did
significant research,
and I dropped out
of medical school
to pursue this.
Did you quit
medical school?
I did.
You're doing this
full-Time?
Full-time.
So...
it's an interesting idea.
I'm just trying
to get my mind around
whether that would cause me
to buy the shirt.
It's not the shirt.
It's the technology.
Think of it as a new medium
for branding and messaging.
So is your strategy
to license the technology
to players
in the apparel business?
Uh, to license the technology
not only to apparel players,
but we can integrate
the technology
into other textiles.
So the $140,000 you've sold,
has that been licensing?
No, what we've done is, we have
full decoration services that--
We take
other people's shirts,
like high school teams,
college teams,
we put this chemical
on the shirt.
It's subsequently applied
to the shirt,
and then the shirt's ready
to go to be sold.
Ben--
You have to sweat to see
the imprint.
No, you don't. That's the beauty
of the technology.
Mm-hmm.
Think kids in water parks.
Spray the shirt down,
and secret logos
or graphics appear.
Well, then you have
to be wet to actually see
what follows...
you have to be wet.
Ben, would
this model work...
and--Mm.
If you simply gave me
the chemical
or a way to make
the chemical? Like--
That's the endgame.
We want to license
this technology out.
Do you need to have--
Have you approached
any companies
about a licensing deal?
We have.
Hurley is very interested
in the product right now.
I have a question about
the sweat factor.
I can work out for two hours
and barely sweat.
How hard do you have
to sweat--
You're not working out
hard enough.
A 20-Minute workout
for an average individual
will produce the results
that you need.
So the logo goes away
pretty quickly, Ben.
Yeah. Unfortunately,
you sweat from the inside,
so when you spray it
from the outside,
the effect isn't as good.
Okay, so let's see it work.
(spritzes)
I don't--I'm sorry.
I don't know.
I'm not seeing a whole lot.
I don't know there.
(chuckles) Yeah, um...
(chuckles) I--
have you had any complaints
from customers that
it wasn't as visible--
Not at all. This is--
This never happens.
This is falling apart
right here.
Come on, Ben.
You got one foot in the tank
and another
on a banana Peel.
There you can see.
See, I still can't see
the, uh...
well, I can read it.
"stronger. Be stronger."
The "stronger" Part
doesn't come out
as strong.
Ben, let me see it.
Is the material a cotton?
Can you make that--
can I do it
on 100% cotton?
That's a polyester.
We could do it on 100% cotton.
Ben, can that secondary word
"Stronger" be in black?
Can it pop like
your original logo?
It's all monochromatic.
I'm working on colors right now.
No.
So what is
the half a million dollars--
What are you gonna
use it on?
Well, the idea is to drive
awareness of the technology,
go--Having people go
into the nikes, the hurleys
of the world.
A sales team.
A sales team, and when people
understand the technology
and the word gets out,
it's organic growth.
I know,
but we're paying right now,
and they don't know
anything now about it.
I know, but--
y-You don't see a problem
with that?
No, I-I understand,
But the reality is,
if you look at our sales
and you annualize them,
we're looking at about
a half a million
by the end of the year.
So then you wouldn't need
our money.
No, but I do.
I need your relationships.
So I'm working for my money,
once I give it to you.
You see the technology.
There's a value in this.
Obviously you see
something here.
I think--I think you do.
I'm out.
We just got a p.O.
For the U.S. Naval academy.
They're gonna order
1,500 shirts now,
1,500 shirts
in the next month.
1,500?
Ben, you're a chemist.
Let's reverse engineer
the equation
for this value, okay?
(mouths word)
What should I be making
in a company
that I want to sell somebody
for $2 1/2 million?
$500,000.
What do you--Right.
Yeah.
How much are you making?
We did $140,000 so far.
You're making squat.
He's charging you
25 times...
(speaks indistinctly)
I'm looking for a partnership.
I'm looking for somebody
that's gonna help
This business grow.
Well, see, but that--
You've identified
This is a great technology.
You're right. No, I get
that, Ben. I get that, right?
Yeah.
So part of your role
in coming into the shark tank is
being able to strategize,
and when you ask
for too much money...
what you need is us.
Absolutely.
Because you strategized
incorrectly, I'm out.
Ben, when I hear
a valuation like this,
I get a little insulted.
Why would I ever give you money
at a value that guarantees
I'll never get a return?
Here's the thing.
It's a $54 billion industry.
The biggest players--
Every guy comes in here
and says that.
All right, but nike has
a 4% market share...
Everybody says that.
Highly fragmented.
You're a long line of guys...
if we had one--
That have made
this strategic mistake.
I'm very frustrated
'cause I like the idea,
but then I see stupidity.
I really do.
I see somebody's who's arrogant
and insulted me financially,
which I take
a lot of offense in.
I'm out.
Ben, my reaction is--
is This is too monochromatic.
You can't read it.
It takes too much sweat
to actually get the big bonus
of reading something
on your chest, so I'm out
because the product is
terrible, I think, honestly.
You know, Ben, I'm not sold
on the product.
Uh, I do think
it's a little bit gimmicky.
I'm out.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you very much.
I asked for too much money,
and I'm paying the price now,
but I think
they were shortsighted,
'cause this technology is
revolutionary.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank is
mark Sullivan,
who believes he has
a visionary invention that
can do good
and make money.
♪♪♪
Hi.
My name is mark Sullivan,
and I'm an inventor
with over 1,000 inventions,
and the technology
I'm offering you today
is the Sullivan generator.
For only $1 million,
I am offering
10% of my generator.
This is
an electric generator
which harnesses
the spin of the earth.
It works by taking
in salt water.
It processes the water
and leaves behind
the mineral precipitates.
The water vapor is then
delivered to a vortex chamber,
where the coriolis effect
spins this into a hurricane,
which drives the turbines,
which makes electricity.
The waste products are
the mineral precipitates
manganese and gold.
What?
Gold.
Gold?
G-O-L-D?
G-O-L-D.
Let him finish.
We suck water in.
We make it spin
really fast...
right.
And we produce electricity
on one hand...
right.
And gold bars
on the other.
That's it.
The waste products can be
$96 billion in gold,
so we can have over 200
of these generators set up
all over the world.
They're, uh, controlled
over the internet.
With your help
and your business acumen,
together we can develop
this new technology
and leave a lasting legacy
of goodness.
Mark, how long are you
visiting earth?
(mark C., Barbara, and Robert
laugh)
What's your background, mark?
I have degrees
in biomedical engineering
and physics.
I've been working on This
for several years.
You're the first that
I have presented this to,
so you have
a great opportunity right now.
What's going on
in that little tank?
Well, this is just a model
to illustrate
the force of the conservation
of angular momentum.
I don't know what the hell
you're talking about
or what you said,
so with that, I'm out.
If your theory is correct,
would it not seem to make sense
that in real-Life hurricanes,
there would be sprinkles
of gold left somewhere?
That's right.
The gold is left
in the ocean.
So if I went to a hurricane area
in the ocean,
how much gold would I get out
of that salt water?
We process
1 cubic mile of salt water,
we're gonna get
1,500 tons of gold
as a waste product.
Yeah. Yeah,
but you've still got...
what?
To be able to process
a cubic mile of--
Of water--Of ocean water.
That's enormous.
How big is
the entire machine?
This is 100 feet tall.
So you're creating
a synthetic hurricane
and trapping it
in a 100-Foot-High tube.
That's right.
If I gave you
$1 million today,
how long would it take
to build the first one?
We would h--Be operational
in nine months.
No way.
Way.
My... Meter is going
through the roof.
It's going, "Bing, Bing, Bing,
Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing."
I'm out.
What about
the other 999 inventions?
Did you ever make any money
with those?
My inventions are making
over $1 billion per year.
Can you name one that
I would know?
Artificial hearts,
artificial kidney--
You invented
the artificial heart?
It's a left ventricular
assist device.
Do you get money
from that?
I do get some royalties,
and I get royalties
from my music.
I write music. I design,
uh, clothing. I sew.
(daymond, Robert,
and Kevin laugh)
I want to know what
you sew.
Leather,
and I sew ladies' skirts
and vests and handbags.
(laughs)
(chuckles)
It's a very fine line...
go ahead.
Of being a genius and crazy.
Yeah.
I'm just asking you,
has anybody ever said
to you, "you're crazy"?
no, I've won
engineering awards.
I don't smoke.
I don't drink.
I'm thinking
maybe you should.
(laughs)
Mark, if I gave you
$50,000,
and Kevin gave you
the other $950,000...
(laughs)
How much gold would we make
from the $50,000 machine?
It would be determined
by the flow of water
processed through
the generator.
Mark, may I interrupt you?
That might be
the reason why--
May I interrupt him
just a minute?
Uh-huh. Yes, ma'am.
I'm out.
Look, mark, enough of this.
I made you a legitimate offer.
I'll give you the...
(laughs)
(chuckles)
I'll give you the $50,000
if you can get O'Leary to
give you the other $950,000,
'cause that man loves gold
more than any other human being
I've ever met.
Or I could just go buy
some gold
with my $950,000.
(laughs
and speaks indistinctly)
But that's not fun.
That's not fun.
Look, mark,
it's very interesting,
but most of it's
nutbar factor six.
I'm out.
Well, mark, you weren't able
to convince O'Leary,
and only for that reason,
I'm out, too.
I-I guess you just didn't
get it, you know,
but that can happen, and, uh,
this is the--the plight
of the inventor.
Good luck.
Okay. Bye-Bye.
This way, mark. This way.
Thank you.
(chuckles)
(mark c.) Oh, my God.
That guy was great.
Maybe we're just
too simple.
Maybe that was the best deal
in the tank this year.
I think so, man.
In America, this is the land
of opportunity and innovation,
and inventors like me are
what will save America.
♪♪♪
Last season,
we watched James Martin
walk away from an offer
from Kevin O'Leary
for his
wine-by-the-Glass business
copa di vino.
I'll buy 51% of it
for $600,000.
The opportunity is greater
than that.
I am going to go buy
$1,000 bottle of wine tonight,
and I'm gonna drink it,
because I'm weeping
for the opportunity lost.
Cheers.
(daymond and Robert) Cheers.
He's a dead man walking.
Right.
(chuckles)
Just another deal.
(man) Let's see what
he's up to now.
You know, walking away
from a deal
from Kevin O'Leary was brutal,
but at the same time,
Kevin O'Leary only wanted
the patents.
He didn't see any value
in the brand.
We wanted to build
copa di vino as a brand.
Do you have those samples?
I'm proud to say
that copa di vino has gone
to $5 million in sales
in one year.
Take this one to chicago.
Business is booming.
We're with some
of the largest retailers
in the world--Walmart, ralphs,
krogers, 7-Eleven.
You name it, they want us.
This way a little.
Take it in. Take it in.
Looking good.
My company is growing so fast
that we're putting
all our revenue back
into inventory.
We need capital,
and we need capital fast...
thanks a lot.
And that's why I'm going back.
♪♪♪
No!
(laughs)
I don't believe it.
Ohh.
I'm back.
God, are you kidding me?
I thought we'd kicked you
to the curb.
James, you're still dead
to me.
(laughs)
Nice to see all of you.
My name's James Martin,
founder and c.E.O.
Of copa di vino.
I'm here today seeking
an investment of $300,000
for 5% of my company.
You may all recall
copa di vino,
"wine by the glass."
No corkscrews.
No extra glasses.
Just open and enjoy.
Last time I was here,
I told you
I would revolutionize
the wine world.
I had just launched
the concept,
but I had
had over $500,000 in sales
in the first six months.
Well, this year
I'm on track to sell
over $5 million in sales.
In truth, I cannot keep up
with demand.
I literally have
twice the amount of orders
than I can produce,
and to catch up,
I have to build
a second bottling line,
and that is
why I'm here today,
to give you
that elusive second bite
of the apple.
(chuckles)
We missed out on
a perfect opportunity last time.
Kevin,
last time I was here,
you told me
you were gonna drink
a $1,000 bottle of wine
While weeping over
the missed opportunity.
Agonize no more.
This time around,
we're gonna make a deal,
and to commemorate
the occasion,
I've bottled
a $1,000 bottle of wine
in my copa glass.
With your investment,
we'll drink these together,
and we'll toast to the millions
we'll continue to roll in.
I ask all of you,
please take a second look
at copa di vino
and become my partners.
Can you hear it?
That's opportunity
knocking again.
Last time, you were stuck
on the idea of taking
a now-Proven technology
and hoarding it
for just yourself,
when the real opportunity was
to give the entire wine industry
a license
of this exact technology
so that all wines could
be sold this way.
Instead of just making
$5 million,
you could make $500 million,
and I wept like a child,
drinking
a $2,000 bottle of wine,
realizing I was unable
to help you out of your madness
and your insanity.
Have you repented?
(mark, Robert,
and Barbara laugh)
What was the offer
you walked away from last time?
Last time I was here...
it was my offer.
You offered $600,000 for 51%
of the I.P. And the patents.
And you know what?
I said it was a great deal.
It was even more
than I would have offered.
You screwed up.
You guys have
great memories.
James, what are you drinking
to come back here?
You know we're not gonna be
as gentle and as tender
as we was last time
to you.
I don't remember gentle
when I was here last time.
(sharks laugh)
That was gentle.
Oh, that's good.
That's great.
I do remember Someone
standing here
and s--and professing
the value of the brand,
and now I see someone
standing in front of you
that's proven the value
of the brand...
James...
(speaks indistinctly)
And the value
of the patents that
you're really interested in
are now much more valuable.
Uh, look, look,
when I last saw you,
I said you were
a dead man walking
and you were dead to me.
Now are you a ghost
or are you real?
You know what? I bottled
a $1,000 bottle of wine
so you and I could go ahead
and put the past in the past.
In the decision
to bottle this,
I created a name for you
for this wine.
I call it...
(laughs)
the dead man walking.
(Robert and Barbara laugh)
This is for you, Buddy.
I like it, James,
but I want to ask you a question
that's gonna help set you free.
What if we could take
the technology
to the largest three players
in the wine industry
and license it to them?
You keep doing
what you're doing...
Mm-hmm.
'cause you love it.
You'll pay me a royalty,
of which you'll get 49%...
mm-hmm.
And I will quadriple
your net worth in two quarters
by simply taking this to people
that have distribution
50 TIMES larger than you,
and every time
they sell something,
you'll make money.
So we're right back...
why not just--
to the original offer.
Yep.
Of course it is,
'cause it's the right thing
to do.
If my memory serves me
correctly,
you passed out
some wine the last time.
Mm.
You know, try--
Try passing wine out
this easily
with any other brand.
There you go.
Thank you.
I'm waiting
for the good stuff.
Wait. Hold on a second.
Well, I wasn't interested
last time,
and I just want to be
thoroughly entertained
while you go back and forth
with these guys,
so I'm out,
but thanks for the wine.
You're welcome.
James, I don't want to do battle
with you anymore.
I want to figure out how
to do business with you,
'cause I want to drink
that good wine,
not the swill Barb is drinking.
(laughs)
I'd like to figure out,
how can I invest in the piece
that has the real value,
because wineries are
a labor of love,
and you are in love.
I hate that business.
I love the packaging business
you have.
You have
a huge global opportunity,
and I so much want to be
your partner in that.
Look, I have
a better understanding
than I did last time,
but I'm still not comfortable
that a $6 million valuation,
even with the m-Marginal value
of the intellectual property,
is worth the investment.
You need to start telling us
that you're negotiable
on the equity portion.
Very well said. I-I agree that
we are here to negotiate.
I think it's
really important for you
to take some of the information
that I have more seriously,
that I-I, at this point,
am an expert.
No one in--in the world today
knows wine by the glass
in the marketplace
like I do.
I agree,
so what's it gonna take?
What are we gonna do here?
Give--Give me a chance
to explain the valuation, okay?
Most national brands,
which we are becoming,
sell for 2 1/2 to 3 times
the gross dollar value.
When you just sell a brand,
then it shifts over to--
but you're not there yet.
You're not there yet,
'cause you're--You're--
You're not there yet.
When will I be there?
Look--
after you've done--
One more year.
No, no.
But you're not.
I just feel like...
James, you know...
(speaks indistinctly)
When you just came
in here again,
I was happy to see you
for some reason,
like, "ohh,"
like an old friend...
mm.
And he got
a new haircut...
(chuckles)
But as I'm listening
and listening,
I'm having the same
visceral reaction to you.
For some reason,
and I hope you take it well,
I didn't like you then,
and I don't like you now...
But take it well.
But I don't where
that's coming from.
I just have to say
I'm out.
I'm not arguing that
you see it at $6 million,
but you have to see that
we see it at something less.
Potentially there's
somewhere in the middle
that we can meet,
but we're asking you
to start to move the needle
and start to move the valuation
so that we can respond.
Normally we don't do that.
Normally we say, "you know what?
We're just gonna tell you,"
but you know
what you're doing.
You're very aware
of your industry.
You're very aware of
the components of your business,
so we're asking you.
It sounds like you guys have
an interest in this, right?
If we can work on a valuation,
we may be able to make
a deal here, correct?
Which, uh,
I've been saying for...
a long time.
Too many times.
(chuckles) Yeah.
You've tortured me so long,
I'm gonna put an offer
out anyways.
I'll do the $300,000 for 12%,
'cause that's exactly
what you're worth right now.
So you're saying the company's
worth $2 1/2 million today?
That's exactly
what it's worth.
You have something of tremendous
potential here globally.
At some point, I know
I'll be able to convince you
to set it free,
and you'll make so much money,
you can kick back
on the copa hillside and say,
"Kevin O'Leary was right.
I'm so lucky to have him
as a partner."
That's what's gonna happen,
and my ticket
to entry is $300,000.
All right.
You beat me into a pulp.
Give me the good stuff.
I can't take this anymore.
Wow.
Before you make
a decision...
♪♪♪
two sharks are out,
and Kevin O'Leary has an offer
on the table for James
and his unique
wine-by-the-glass business,
copa di vino.
I'll do the $300,000 for 12%,
'cause that's exactly what
you're worth right now.
Before you make a decision,
I'm gonna try to change
his mind on something.
W--Do you have anybody
you can call that you know,
or you gotta go
to the bathroom or anything?
I do have someone to call.
Go make your phone call,
'cause we need a moment.
Okay. All right.
Okay?
Okay. Thank you.
12% isn't a whole lot of skin
in the game. That's my problem.
That's my issue with it.
Right. That's my problem.
I think we offer him
more money
at a slightly lower valuation
among three of us...
mm.
I like it.
So we get more equity,
more in the upside, right?
Why not try for 30%, mark,
so we get 10% each?
I don't think he'll go for it,
but we can negotiate.
But try that.
(Jim) I think they're
not appreciating
you've got a proven technology,
a proven product.
You've proven
there's a market,
and when I started
Sam Adams,
everybody thought it was
a dumb idea,
and nobody would invest,
and I only got, like,
lowball offers,
and look where
Sam Adams is today.
Passion will take you
a long way.
Watch what he does
when he comes back.
He's gonna be
complicated again.
James, who did you call?
I called Jim Koch.
He's the founder
of Samuel Adams.
He basically the--the father
of craft brewing in America,
and Jim's been instrumental
in--in bringing my company
to this level.
What did he say to you?
Jim basically wanted
to make sure that,
whoever I'm becoming,
uh, a partner with,
that they share in the dream,
they understand the vision,
and they understand
the possibilities.
Is he an, uh,
an investor in the company
or an EQUITY owner
in the company?
Jim's an advisor.
An advisor. He doesn't have
any equity at all?
No equity.
Then why didn't he just
give you the money
for your extra line
that you need?
The best advice is gonna come
from someone who's not vested
in your company.
You know,
I really respect Koch.
He's a legend
in the beverage industry.
No question. But he's not
spending his money right here.
So what did he tell you to do
with the $300,000 for 12%
that Kevin offered you?
You know, uh, basically,
it's--It's half the price
of what the value
of--Of my company is,
and he--He recommended that,
if I'm interested
in trying to have a partner
as established as mark cuban,
that it would be valuable to me
to pay additionally,
above what I'm asking for
for an investment, of 3%,
so $300,000 for 8%
of the company.
That's your counter?
That's my counter.
Mark cuban's not interested
in that.
And tell me why, mark.
Because it's not enough skin
in the game.
Because you want
the value of the sharks
and what we bring
to the table,
and that's an effort...
Mm-hmm.
Right?
Just like you've created
a valuation...
Yeah.
We have our own valuations
of our time
and our effort as well,
and what I'm saying--
It's just not worth it.
What I suggested
and they agreed with was that
we need to get significant skin
in the game,
but it's worth putting in
more money to get it,
so what we suggested was
$600,000 for 30%,
because that's $200,000 apiece,
10% equity apiece,
three rock stars
to help support you
and build your brand,
and you still retain 70%,
so you get significant amounts
of leverage,
and you have the capital,
should you need it, to expand
into other product lines
to fund your growth.
Twice the money you came here
looking for.
I agree that having
more skin in the game
makes a lot more sense
for you guys. I agree that
that could be a greater value
and asset to my company.
Does it get us a deal
in the stadium next year,
in the Dallas mavericks?
It gets you first crack.
I can't make a promise
just because we have
a service organization
that I have to go through.
Uh-huh.
But when we were talking,
you know, I own
the landmark theatres,
and quite a few of them sell
alcohol and single-Serve wine,
and the bigger theatres serving
Alcohol makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
Why can't...
the--
You're talking yourself out
of a sale.
You need to make a decision.
Don't do this again, James.
James, you've done something
nobody in the tank
has ever done.
You've been given
the American dream to come back.
Who's--Who's in on this?
It's you, you, and you?
Yes, sir.
All three.
(sighs)
Kevin, if I get that phone call
from you all the time that says,
"We've gotta
split this company up..."
No.
James, mark and I will
keep Kevin in line. Don't worry.
You've convinced me
from the very get-Go
because you went
from $500,000 to $5 million,
and then $12 million next year.
You were right
about that concept.
You need to make a decision
right now
on what you want to do.
I wanna be partners
with you guys...
But if I trade my company
30% for $600,000
and basically give my company
at that kind of discount,
and I don't have
any kind of guarantee
that I-I can even get into,
uh, you know,
the single stadium
that you control,
then I'm in a position where
I'm trying to understand
what kind of value
that you might be adding.
Then you just have to decide.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
James, you wouldn't have
come back here
if you didn't see value
in the tank in us.
So don't ask us to start
selling ourselves
back to you now.
You're the one that came back.
We're not--We didn't go see you.
No more talking.
We made a very fair offer
to you.
You've gotta make a decision.
It's a $1 million
bottle of wine.
(laughs) Yeah.
30% of the company.
That should go
for $1.2 million,
and I'm gonna sell it
for...
$600,000.
I don't think you're
thinking clearly on that.
Well, hang on. Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Kevin, I think he's saying yes.
What are you saying?
James, let me drink
one of those with you...
Kevin. Kevin.
In celebration of the deal.
(Robert) James,
what are you saying?
(sets down cup)
I'm out.
You know what? I'm out.
You screwed around.
You're playing games,
and there's nothing I hate more
than playing games.
(slapping hand)
You knew the number. You knew
the number when you walked out,
you knew the number
when you walked in,
and you came in
and created drama.
That makes--
No.
I came looking
to make partners with you
at a very reasonable valuation
that was done by experts,
not by someone that says, "well,
I see what the wine industry is.
My friends Have wineries."
These are the top experts
in the country
who have told me
what my company's worth.
But none of them
gave you any money.
You know as well as we do
that it's worth what
someone will pay for it.
I'm just telling you, James,
I'm out.
Robert, Kevin,
you guys gonna split it?
Yeah, well,
you know, James, I...
I'm--I'm really out.
(laughs)
I mean, you just came here
to waste our time.
(Robert) So...
cheers.
(exhales deeply)
I'm sorry, but I think
I've earned this.
(sharks laughing)
I came here in good faith,
really wishing for these sharks
to become my partners.
No one could share
in that vision.
It was all about the money
and whether they could
get a discount
on the value of my company.
I won't be back.